If this were TV, we'd start with something
like, "Cute, cuddly and deadly.
These are the pets you CAN'T own, but wish
you could!"
Hey everyone, welcome to DNews!
I'm Trace and pets are fun, right?
Until they're not pets and they're wild animals...
but who decides where that line is?
The federal government says pets don't include
exotic or wild animals, but what is EXOTIC?
Well, the definition is SO broad, that there's
no easy way to define it.
In the Dictionary, it's defined as anything
non-native to the region in question -- but
that's even BROADER.
In the U.S. it comes down to state laws, but
then some states classify new cat and dog
breeds as exotic pets, while others have zero
regulations for a-typical pets.
We almost got a ferret when I was a kid.
They're regulated or banned in many states
and are the poster-child for illegal pets
that you just want to cuddle.
A ferret is the domesticated version of a
European Polecat.
They're related to the weasel and the mink
and are primarily from, you probably guessed,
Europe!
They were declared bloodthirsty vermin under
the reign of Elizabeth the First, and were
almost extinct in Britain -- though they've
since rebounded.
Owning a ferret as a pet can be tricky, they're
cute, but they smell due to natural scent
glands on their backsides.
In California, they've been illegal since
1933 because they're non-native, but really
if a ferret was to get loose and procreate
with another ferret or a related species...
there wouldn't be a natural predator to control
the population and well, that would stink.
Other pets like hedgehogs and chinchillas
tow the exotic line as well.
The African Pygmy hedgehog is the pet you'd
usually see on the 'net, and they're illegal
to possess in California, Georgia, Pennsylvania
and Hawaii and restricted in Maine and Arizona,
but most states are cool with them.
Being an African species, the worry is their
ability to start invasive, non-native populations
and overrun the natural environment.
Hedgehogs require a lot of socialization when
they're young to keep them from stabbing you
with their spines when nervous.
They might be cute, but they can definitely
be a difficult pet to own.
One of the most exotic, interesting pets people
try to own are chimpanzees.
Twenty-one states ban the possession of non-human
primates, and 12 more have regulations for
their ownership.
Even so, many jump in without doing research
which can be downright devastating.
Chimpanzees share 99% of their genetic information
with humans.
Getting a chimp is akin to getting a child
for 50 to 60 years that is seven times stronger
than an adult man, and will never be fully
domesticated.
They've got their own physical, emotional
and mental needs, and when they're not met...
terrible things can happen.
In 2009, a 55-year-old Connecticut woman was
attacked by her friend's pet chimp and was
permanently disfigured.
The illegal pet trade is kind of ridiculous.
For example, there are more tigers kept as
pets than there are tigers in the wild!
Owning definitively exotic animals have come
back to bite in some places.
One man in Ohio owned over 50 lions, Bengal
tigers, wolves, cheetahs, leopards, monkeys,
apes, a grizzly bear, ... he had a lot.
In 2011, he freed the animals and committed
suicide.
Yeah.
That being said, there are plenty of people
who still crave the feeling of bringing the
wild into their home.
Some feel it's a connection with nature, others
love the uniqueness of owning something no
one else has...
But wild animals are still wild.
And yet there are a lot of exotic beasts that
you CAN own, at least in certain states.
If you wanna know what some of the weirdest
ones are, be sure to check the video on it
from our friends over at Animalist News.
What exotic pet would you own if you could
and why?
Tell us down below, and be sure to subscribe
for more DNews.
Thanks for watching!